hello guys my name is Archana and
welcome back to my say boss boss series
so today we're going to be talking about
strings and specifically something
called small string optimization or SSR
for short what does it mean why do we
care and how does it improve our string
experience now strings are a very
interesting topic
I think in Sabo's lost or injured just
in any language in general because they
have all of this kind of negative stigma
I guess associated with them they have
this reputation of being slower and
don't even start talking about
performance to a C++ programmer because
man if something's slower in C++ it's
really easy to look at someone's code
see them using strings in a way that you
just frown upon and then immediately
think that they're either not a good
programmer or they're doing things that
stupid slower way there's just so much
negativity associated with strings
believe me but I'm here to tell you that
it's not all bad and in fact sometimes
when you do see someone using a string
maybe it's not as bad as you think
now strings in general I think I
something they're just gonna continue
talking about every now and then on this
channel it's impossible to program
without strings but on the other hand
reducing your usage of strings in your
code can significantly speed it up
depending on how in fact you do use them
so expect this topic to stay around but
today specifically we're going to be
looking at how small strings are
actually optimized by the sibyl's law
standard library so that they end up
being not as bad as you think but first
I want to thank hosting out for
sponsoring this video if you guys have
not heard of hosting out hosting it is a
fast and secure web hosting platform now
I think that nowadays in 2020 pretty
much everyone should have a website if
you don't have a website and you're
trying to become a programmer well you
need some kind of website so that you
can easily show people what it is you're
working on and what you've achieved
especially if you're looking for a job
don't even get me started on that and
what people don't realize is that the
added benefit to all this is that you
will know how to set up a website the
fact that you've got a website on the
Internet to me immediately means that
well you know how to set up a website
you know how web
single accent that's a perp in and of
itself now there's a lot to love about
hosting us specifically apart from being
really really fast really intuitive the
fact that they have built-in Diagnostics
to help you along the way of something
like your DNS isn't set up correctly
apart from all of that they're also
really really affordable and I
absolutely love that because web hosting
should be accessible to as many people
as possible even if you don't have a lot
of money to spend on this and hosting
our I really think they hit the ball on
that because they are super amazing and
affordable a lot of these kind of
cheaper web hosts just don't seem to do
that great of a job but hosting our is
not some cheap web host hosting it is
it's just a really good web hosting
platform regardless of the price so if
you don't have a website yet and you
want to get online or you're with some
other web host and you're not enjoying
that experience and you want to come
over to a good one
then definitely check out hosting and
there'll be a link in the description
you can save up to 91% off their hosting
plans if you use this code code chenna
so definitely check out hosting out if
you guys need any kind of web hosting
link in the description below alright
strings string string strings strings
strings where would we be without
strings probably not where we are today
whether that's a good thing or a bad
thing don't know one of the reasons that
we don't like strings is because they
tend to allocate memory and C++ heap
allocations bad those things are just
grouped together so much even though I
mean arguably speaking memory allocation
maybe isn't that bad anyway I better not
say anything cuz so because we know that
creating a standard string results in a
memory allocation a lot of people try
and kind of avoid that they'll try and
reduce their kind of string usage or
they'll try and come up with creative
ideas of how to use strings or at worst
case scenario they'll just berate you
for using strings because why you
allocating so much memory all the time
don't you know that that is bad but as I
mentioned I'm here to tell you that
north it's not necessarily bad because
the C++ center library has maybe
somewhat surprisingly thought of this
and they've put a stop to it by saying
that small strings that is strings that
are not exceedingly long
they don't need to be heap-allocated I
can just allocate a little stack based
buffer that is not heap-allocated and
that is gonna be my static string
storage for Strings that are below a
certain length now what that actual
length is to define a small string can
absolutely vary based on the surplus
plus standard library that you're using
but here in Visual Studio 2019 that
length seems to be 15 characters if you
have a string that is 15 characters or
less it will not allocate memory on the
heap it will just use that stack buffer
as I mentioned however if you do have a
string that is 16 characters or above
that's gonna hit malloc and you know
heap Alec and whatever on earth function
is used to allocate memory on whatever
platform you're on so in other words if
you have a string that's quite small you
don't have to worry about using a
conch-shell pointer or trying to
micromanage or optimize that kind of bit
of your code because likely that's not
going to result in a heap allocation
anyway so without further ado let's dive
into Visual Studio and actually take a
look at how this works behind the scenes
and see it in action I'm just gonna make
a string I'm gonna call it churner now
this is a really small string it's only
six characters which would throw a lot
of people off because if you assign this
to a standard string this is kind of
implication of a heap allocation a lot
of people might choose to actually do
something like this like a Const our
name because this is something that is
clearly a static string meaning we're
not gonna be appending anything to it
we're not taking it in from a file or
from like the console or anything like
that it's just a simple static string so
why then would I use a standard string
if that comes with that whole heap
allocation overhead well here's a thing
it doesn't come with a heap allocation
overhead because this fits the criteria
of a small string in C++ which means it
will in fact just be stored in a
statically allocated buffer that does
not push the heap at all so let's take a
look at this in action what I'm actually
gonna do is something a little bit
different instead of just straightaway
jumping to a practical example and then
maybe taking a look at you know
overriding operator knew which I think
we will do eventually in this video as
well I'm just gonna go to the definition
of string now let's take a look at this
I'll hide this solution Explorer so we
string as a basic string now there's a
few things that we need to know it here
mainly the fact that the element type
here is a char so if we go to this class
here and we take a look at it we have
this element type here which we know is
char if we go down to the constructor
that actually takes in some kind of
buffer of characters which looks like
what this thing is here so we have this
kind of Const LM pointer and LM of
course is a Const our pointer in this
case now some of this stuff applies to
earn the debug mode and other stuff
replies to release mode we'll take a
look at that a bit later but the main
function here is a sign which takes in
the actual pointer being that const char
pointer which is in fact the word
Cherno here and then also account which
in this case would be 6 because Cherno
is 6 characters if we go into this
assign function it might be a little bit
difficult to find the right one but in
this case it would be the one that takes
in that element that of course redirects
to something else and does some some
extra conversion stuff but if we drill
down even more and we find the right one
here which is actually just a little bit
above here you can see this is the one
that takes in that pointer and then the
count of how many characters it is
there's this little if statement here
and this basically says that if the
count meaning the size of the string is
below a certain value which is this kind
of reserved size which we'll check out
in a minute then actually what happens
is we simply get what looks like to be
an already existing buffer of memory and
simply move our characters over into
that buffer of memory and that's it and
then we just return it so there's no
allocation at all whereas here in this
case if it doesn't pass this if
statement test we actually call this
reallocate for function which as you can
see eventually over here actually calls
an allocate function and that allocate
function will in fact hit the new
operator and will cause a heap
allocation let's go back a little bit
here what is this my res variable it's
the current storage reserved for string
so in other words it's just that reserve
size so anything below this or equal to
this will constitute a small string and
if we take a look at where this is
actually set inside here you can see
that it gets set to buffer size minus 1
and buffer size for us is this scary Val
buff's I
which is in fact a constant expression
and in this case it's actually going to
be 16 and we eventually subtract one so
we have 15 meaning 15 is that maximum
amount of characters that constitutes a
small string so that's kind of all the
code in just a little bit kind of
looking at how everything works here and
if I go back to that assign function
whichever one it is then you can see
that the presence of this if statement
does in fact result in nor heap
allocations for a string that is 15
characters or smaller and we can of
course test this out so what I like
doing is writing this little operator
new here we'll just take in the size
here this will just simply return a
malloc with the right size here the
benefit here is that we can actually put
a breakpoint and I'll also add some
custom code here to actually print this
so we'll just say allocating and then
size and then bytes yeah
okay so let's not worry about this let's
put a C in get so that if we don't click
close our console and then let's launch
this alright so check this out we
actually allocate 8 bytes even though
our string clearly is below 15
characters that's another little quirk
with visual geo string class it's
basically something that only happens in
debug mode but if we switch to release
mode and we launch this then you'll see
we have Noor allocations at all but if I
expand this and make this a little bit
more than these 6 characters so 7 8 9 10
11 12 13 14 15 so that's exactly 15
characters let's take a look at that
still nothing no allocations but the
moment I go into 16 characters you can
see we allocate 32 bytes so it
immediately snaps up to this predefined
value here with just one character less
we have absolutely no heap allocations
but once we tip over to 16 characters or
more we allocate memory on the heap and
that's basically all there is to say for
this video if if you're in care about
any more details you can pretty much
stop watching now just know that in C++
and specifically in this implementation
of the C++ standard library which I'm
using Visual Studio 2019 here any string
that is 15 characters or less does not
cause a heap allocation and in that
sense it's an optimization it's more
efficient it's faster now let's quickly
take a look at what on earth happens in
debug mode that caused
an allocation we'll put a breakpoint
here and I'll also take this back to
Cherno and we'll check it out all right
so this allocation comes from external
code let's just show that external code
and let's go up to here which is
probably going to show us what we want
to see I'll just make some more room
here there it is contain a proxy pointer
so this is what causes the allocation
now this container proxy pointer you can
see is equal to this rebind Alec T
situation which is actually a template
argument for this class or I don't even
know what this is to be honest it's so
complicated but basically the point of
this whole thing is that you can see
that this is only the case if the
iterator debug level is not zero because
in that sense this part of the code gets
compiled however if the debug level is
zero which is what it would be in
release mode you can see that instead
this get proxy allocator is a fake
allocator and this fake allocator does
absolutely nothing
so this container proxy 12 which
eventually actually causes that new
allocation to take place so it turns out
that it's a little bit of a red herring
in the sense that it's a debug only
allocation and it's not in fact small
string optimization not working it's
just the case for all debug strings okay
so that's a small string optimization
strings that are sufficiently small will
not cause any heap allocations and thus
will result in your program running
faster it's a cute little trick they
worked into the C++ standard library to
make it that little bit faster how
thoughtful
anyway hope you guys enjoyed this video
if you did please hit that like button
drop a comment below with what you would
like to see next I'm about to come out
with a whole bunch of like data
structures and patterns and all of that
kind of stuff videos that's what I'm
kind of more or less gravitating towards
with the C++ series don't forget to
check out hosting up up to 91 percent
off web hosting and I will see you guys
next time goodbye
[Music]